[Music]
sounding of fanfare for the new king
westminster hall home to much of our
nation's history from medieval to modern
times
but few occasions compare with this the
second elizabethan age is over
parliament welcoming a new monarch and a
new reign
past prime ministers and
parliamentarians here to pay their
respects
and to offer the new king addresses of
condolence led by the speakers of each
parliamentary house
deep as our grief is
we know yours is deeper we offer our
heartfelt sympathy to you and all the
royal family
whatever his private grief the king here
for a very public and performative event
his fast speech to parliament meeting
the enormity of that moment
i cannot help but feel the weight
of history
which surrounds us
and which reminds us
of the vital parliamentary traditions
to which members of both houses
dedicate yourselves
a hereditary monarchy renewing its
commitment to parliamentary democracy
parliament
is the living and breathing instrument
of our democracy
that your traditions
are ancient
we stay
in the construction of this great hall
and the reminders of medieval
predecessors
of the office
to which i have been called
while very young
her late majesty
pledged herself to serve her country
and her people
and to maintain the precious principles
of constitutional government
which lie at the heart
of our nation
this vow she kept
with unsurpassed devotion
she set an example
of selfless duty
which
with god's help
and your counsels
i am resolved faithfully to follow
the national anthem now sung for him the
emotion of this moment plain to see
this ceremony concluded the king and
queen consort now leaving westminster
for hollyrood
and a deep breath in for a monarch not
only mourning his mother but trying to
reassure a nation too
[Applause]
[Music]
the king embarking now on a nationwide
tour leaving this legislature in london
and landing just a couple of hours later
in scotland to address another
arriving at the scottish parliament and
setting aside his ceremonial uniform for
the kilt
two minutes of silence and heads bowed
before the king addressed the
politicians and people of scotland
my mother felt as i do the
greatest admiration for the scottish
people
for their magnificent achievements
and their indomitable spirit
and it was the greatest comfort for her
to know in turn
the true affection
in which she was held
[Music]
two nations in one day this a king well
aware of the task he faces leading a
country from one era to another an
unfamiliar and difficult journey for all
beth rigby sky news westminster